hi I'm Steve Clemens and I have a
question should Ukraine be a member of
NATO let's get to the bottom line
[Music]
Ukraine has always been stuck between a
rock and a hard place historically and
geographically it's always been in
Russia's orbit but in the last 20 years
many of its politicians lobbied to join
the defense against Russia Alliance the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization or
what we all know is NATO in 2008
President George W bush said Ukraine
should be part of NATO and that set off
alarm bells in Russia big time so some
would say that the seats of this war
were planted way back then now NATO
leaders have met in Vilnius Lithuania
and Ukraine is pushing hard to get some
kind of commitment from the alliance so
what are the options and what are the
risks
today we're talking to John mearsheimer
one of America's leading political
scientists and a professor of
international relations at the
University of Chicago his latest book is
coming out this fall how States think
the rationality of foreign policy Dr
mirsheimer it's great to be with you
again thank you for joining the show so
I'm just interested who won and who lost
and what we've seen thus far out of the
NATO Summit
well it's not that black and white Steve
I mean obviously NATO is committed at
some point in the distant future to
bring in Ukraine into the alliance but
they don't want to do it anytime soon
because if it was brought into the
alliance in the middle of a war that
would almost axiomatically involve NATO
and that means the United States in a
war with Russia and we don't want that
the real issue here is that from a
Russian point of view there's nothing
more important than making sure that
Ukraine is not in NATO
so the more we promise to bring Ukraine
into NATO the greater the incentive for
the Russians to wreck Ukraine as a
functioning country and that's really
what's going on here so there are all
sorts of people who feel really good
about the fact that we're working hard
to bring Ukraine into NATO they think
this is a noble cause but they're wrong
the end result of this is that Ukraine
is going to be turned into a
dysfunctional rump state
well right now as we see things
president zielinski is enraged
reportedly uh he's saying they don't
respect NATO I mean you have to
understand that there are a lot of
people that see heroism at least in
those that have tried to defy you know
Russia's Invasion uh and are saying that
this this lack of a clear timeline for
inclusion in NATO is disrespecting that
and I understand where you're coming
from but is there any argument there as
you kind of look at it that maybe when
you have two powers like Russia and and
and the United States and the west and
NATO basically bringing Ukraine as you
said is the the bulwark uh uh you know
in the right side of that Alliance
um might be the right thing is there any
is there any argument for that
in what sense is it the right thing I
mean it's very easy for people in the
west all these virtue signalers who are
not doing the fighting dying to say that
Ukraine should be brought into NATO and
therefore giving the Russians even more
powerful incentives to wreck the country
this makes no sense uh to me uh we
should have abandoned the idea of
bringing Ukraine into NATO long ago and
had we done that there would be no war
today in all likelihood
if these people believe that fueling
this war is going to ultimately lead to
a Ukrainian Victory and then we can
bring Ukrainian Ukraine into NATO
they're living in a Fool's Paradise the
ukrainians are not going to win this war
if anything the Russians are going to
win this war and if you look at what's
happening with this highly touted
Ukrainian counter-offensive that's been
going since June 4th the fact is it's
going no aware and huge numbers of
Ukrainian troops are being slaughtered
and many of their armored fighting
vehicles are being destroyed John you've
written a paper I mean it's a very
compelling paper I highly recommend
people read it it's called The Darkness
ahead where the Ukraine war is headed
and so you see this awful dark future
ahead can you share with our audience a
little bit about what the key pillars of
your argument are
well first of all as you describe it
Steve I think that both sides at this
point in time the Russians on one side
and Ukraine and West and the West on the
other side view each other as
existential threats that have to be
defeated and in a world like that
there's very little room for compromise
because you're dealing with a mortal
enemy that's at the general level at the
more specific level there are two key
issues that are unresolvable the first
has to do with territory and the second
has to do with neutrality let me start
with the second because it gets to what
we were talking about a few minutes ago
the Russians insist that Ukraine not be
in NATO needless to say the ukrainians
at this point in time desperately want
to be into NATO well there's no way that
you can square that Circle either it's
in NATO or it's not in NATO then there's
the issue of territory the fact is that
the Russians have cleaved off about 23
percent of Ukrainian territory and they
have made it clear that they're not
giving it back indeed they have a next
all that territory and they promise to
take more territory
the ukrainians understandably want all
of their territory back again how do you
square that Circle if the Russians keep
the territory the ukrainians can't get
it back and the Russians are going to
keep the territory so you have a
territorial issue as well as the issue
of neutrality and then on top of all
that you have the problem that you
described which is you have two states
or two sides that approach each other as
existential threats that have to be
decisively defeated you know basically
American political support and financial
support of Ukraine we've right now seen
cluster bombs committed we've seen uh
you know a big buy-in essentially from
the United States President into the
outcome of Ukraine where do you see that
going a lot of people saw Joe Biden and
His White House may be acquiescing to a
frozen conflict but then saw the cluster
bombs as maybe an effort to to move this
war more quickly how do you see it
I don't see it like that Steve I think
the Biden Administration knows that for
the foreseeable future that the best
they can hope for is a stalemate and the
cluster bombs are not designed to allow
Ukraine to defeat the Russians on the
battlefield or help them win on the
battlefield the fact is that the most
important weapon on the battlefield in
this war of attrition is artillery and
the Russians have somewhere between a
five to ten to one advantage in
artillery this has massive consequences
but on top of that the ukrainians are
running out of artillery and the reason
that we're giving the ukrainians cluster
bombs at this point in time is so that
that will compensate for the fact that
they're running out of artillery so
we're just trying to maintain the
balance of artillery by substituting
cluster bombs for artillery rounds and
that still means the Russians will have
somewhere between a five to one to ten
to one advantage in artillery if you
categorize cluster bombs as a form of
artillery so this is not going to help
you're basically just stemming the tide
by giving them cluster bombs what does
it say about the world I've talked to
senior your White House officials about
these 155 millimeter shells that they
say are going to decide everything and
that the world that America their all of
its allies aren't producing enough of
this ammunition to supply the 9000
rounds a day that Ukraine needs true it
says that you're doomed if you're
involved in a war of attrition
aside from the balance of resolve the
two things that matter most are number
one the balance of Manpower and number
two the balance of artillery and in
terms of the balance of Manpower the
ukrainians are outnumbered five to one
that means the Russians can produce five
soldiers for every one Ukrainian Soldier
and again remember this is a war of
attrition where you have basically Joe
Frazier and Muhammad Ali standing
toe-to-toe and beating The Living
Daylights out of each other and then the
main weapon on this battlefield is
artillery and by almost all accounts the
Russians have somewhere between to five
to one and ten to one advantage and as I
said before the ukrainians are running
out of artillery this is a colossal
disaster that the ukrainians are facing
and the problem here Steve is that when
we initially got into this war after the
Russians invaded Ukraine and we sided
with ukrainians and we began to supply
them we didn't understand that it would
turn into a protracted War of Attrition
and our ability or the West's ability to
manufacture artillery tubes and
artillery rounds would be of profound
importance and as the war wore on it
became clear that we did not have the
manufacturing capability necessary to
produce an adequate amount of artillery
for the ukrainians and at the same time
the Russians have a truly impressive
ability to pump out artillery rounds and
artillery tubes and furthermore they
have huge stockpiles of artillery so
they have a significant Advantage here
and this is why in good part the
ukrainians are in so much trouble today
on the battlefield and it's why we can't
rectify the situation and it's why we're
giving them cluster bombs which is not
as I said before a magic weapon
are there are there elements on the
Russian side of this that we should be
looking at of miscalculations by Putin
and and fragility on the on the Russian
military side
well there's no question that both sides
made miscalculations uh it's hard to say
what
miscalculations which miscalculations
Putin made simply because we don't have
a lot of information we really don't not
know what he was thinking about as he
went into the war but the one
miscalculation he made was that when he
invaded on February 22nd
should be February 24th of 2022 he went
in with a relatively small force and
it's very clear to me and a number of
other analysts that what he was
interested in doing was getting the
ukrainians to negotiate about the future
of Ukraine in NATO he was interested in
the question of Ukrainian neutrality and
at first it looked like he might succeed
because as you remember in March the
ukrainians and the Russians were
actually negotiating in Istanbul and the
issue the main issue that they were
negotiating about was this question of
neutrality versus Nato membership for
Ukraine now had those negotiations
worked it would have been a brilliant
calculation on Putin's part but
obviously the negotiations failed by
early April and we ended up in this war
of attrition and I think in those
circumstances one could argue that that
Putin miscalculated I would note also
that I think we miscalculated we in the
west as I said before we miscalculated
because we didn't understand how
important artillery production would be
but I think that the West miscalculated
in another way and that is that they
thought that the sanctions the economic
sanctions would bring the Russians to
their knees and therefore we wouldn't
have to worry about producing artillery
in a lengthy War of Attrition because
the Russians would be knocked out by
these massive economic sanctions but the
economic sanctions have had little
effect and therefore we're in this
protract or and therefore artillery
production matters enormously and the
Wagner group and pagosians activities we
had 24 hours of what looked to be a
fairly dramatic Insurrection in Russia
against the Kremlin that disappeared
quickly was it a factor at all
I I don't think it's had any effect on
the battlefield up to this point and I
actually believe with the passage of
time it'll work to Russia's Advantage
but I would qualify that by saying it's
very difficult to know exactly what's
going on here when it first happened and
uh the the Mutiny was shut down I think
almost everybody thought that pagosian
would be thrown in jail then a deal was
worked out where he was going to leave
the country and permanently be stationed
in Bella Russia that didn't work out and
now he's back in Moscow and he's talking
to Putin this is really hard to
understand it's hard to know what's
going on but my clear sense and I may be
wrong here but my clear sense is that
what Putin is up to is he wants to keep
the Wagner group intact and he wants to
keep it in the fight because it is a
formidable fighting for us and at the
same time he wants to keep Goshen on his
side but he will go to Great Lengths to
neuter progressions so that he cannot
cause any significant trouble in the
future if he's successful at doing
something along these lines this will be
a net positive
uh if pogosian doesn't play along he's
going to have to deal with progression
in harsh ways because pagosian has the
potential to cause really big problems
inside the Russian chain of command and
I believe that if he did that it would
ultimately have an effect on events on
the battlefield and given uh the nature
of this war the Russians cannot afford
that so they have to deal with pregosian
one way or the other but exactly how
they do it is hard to say with any
degree of certainty at this point
you have argued in this in this paper
very compellingly that United States and
Russia and a proxy war just can't quit
each other they're just gonna continue
at it but there happen to be a lot of
Republicans who do want to quit this war
if the Republicans come to office will
they be able to find an off ramp in this
conflict or do you think it still keeps
grinding on as you've written
well if I had to bet Steve I would bet
that the Republicans would not take us
out of the war you want to remember that
although there is a substantial slice of
the Republican
party that is in favor of getting out of
Ukraine there are a large number of
Super Hawks in the Republican party and
this includes people like Lindsey Graham
and Mitch McConnell and those folks want
to make sure we don't get out
uh I think that you know even if Trump
gets elected uh that Trump although he
may talk about pulling us out that won't
happen uh in in large part because the
blob or the foreign policy establishment
or the Deep State uh has so much
influence that it's just hard to imagine
uh the United States walking away from
the war in Ukraine at this point in time
and you understand that because Ukraine
has no ability to produce its own
weaponry and in fact uh it can't even
support itself as a functioning
government it absolutely requires our
backing so if we were to walk away in
any meaningful way it would have
devastating consequences for Ukraine
Ukraine would lose uh and Russia would
win I find it hard to believe in a
republican Administration or a
Republican dominated Congress pushing us
down that road I mean it could happen
but I do not think it's likely I think
we're in this one for the forcible
future and I think really the only
interesting question Steve is whether we
get dragged into the fight right at a
globe SEC meeting in May I heard French
president Emmanuel macron and European
commission president Ursula vanderlein
essentially both shrug off then any
chance of near-term NATO membership for
Ukraine but what they're trying to put
in place are essentially bundled
security assurances which to me sounds
like Taiwan is there another strategy
here that sidesteps the NATO question
provides what what macron said was
compelling security assurances that
might possibly deter you know Russian
reinvasion down the road once this
conflict gets resolved is that a
sensible strategy or not
no it doesn't work and this is basically
what you had right before the War uh
I've argued in a number of places uh
Ukraine before the war started on
February 24th 2022 had become a de facto
member of NATO uh this is one of the
reasons that the ukrainians have fought
so well they were trained and armed by
the West between 2014 and 2022. uh
Ukraine had become a de facto member of
NATO and this is categorically
unacceptable to the Russians the
Russians want Ukraine to be a genuinely
neutral country
and the problem is that the ukrainians
want a security guarantee and this is
completely understandable who could
blame the ukrainians for wanting a
security guarantee forever and ever but
the question is who can give them that
security guarantee and the only country
or group of countries that can give them
that
security guarantee or the United States
and the West more generally and once you
do that whether it's done formally
through NATO or informally through NATO
uh you end up in a situation that's
intolerable to the Russians uh and this
is why I find it hard to imagine it's
one of the reasons I find it so hard to
imagine that we're ever going to get a
genuine peace agreement instead I think
we're going to end up in a frozen
conflict I mean just to switch to the
subject of bringing Sweden into the
alliance and bringing Finland into the
alliance in in the west this is seen as
an unalloyed good it's a wonderful thing
it's all designed to check Russian
expansion into all of Europe
I'd make two points one is the Russians
have never had any intention
of extending their military uh into
Eastern Europe much less into Western
Europe the idea that this is the second
coming of the Soviet Union is not a
serious argument so we don't need to
strengthen NATO to contain Russia but
the second point and maybe even more
important point is you want to
understand that the Russians feel that
they're under siege now they feel
encircled and if you look at a map of
NATO uh you could understand why so if
you have a situation where both Finland
and Sweden are in NATO and you look at
the Baltic Sea which matters greatly to
the Russians because kaliningrad is only
reachable by the Baltic Sea this is
going to make the Russians very scared
it's going to make them feel very
insecure it's going to make them feel
vulnerable and the question you want to
ask yourself is this good my
many years studying great power politics
tell me that you don't want to put a
great power in a situation where it is
really scared because you never want to
underestimate the extent to which a
great power that's really scared will
pursue risky strategies
and the Russians may very well pursue a
highly risky strategy one that's highly
undesirable to the West some down the
road because they're scared so I'd be
very careful about scaring the Russians
and I would not hear Steve that the
reason the Russians invaded Ukraine in
my opinion is that they were scared
stiff at the thought of Ukraine becoming
a western bulwark on Russia's borders so
we've played this game once before and
what we're doing here in a very
important way is trying to up the ante
let's not only talk about bringing
Ukraine into NATO let's bring Sweden and
Finland into NATO let's get the Turks
against the Russians let's get the whole
world against the Russians the idea of
scaring a country half to death that has
the largest nuclear Arsenal in the world
and in which many of those nuclear
weapons are aimed at the United States
or the West more generally is in my
humble opinion not a very smart strategy
well we'll have to leave it there
fascinating conversation professor John
meersheimer at the University of Chicago
thank you so much for your candor and
your insights today
my pleasure Steve
so what's the bottom line NATO is a one
for all and all for one Alliance and
Ukraine is just not in the club and
won't be for a long time if ever the
alliance requires all members to agree
to any new member and the U.S France
Germany Hungary and turkey have all
expressed reservations most eastern
European capitals are frustrated and the
issue is dividing allies who see the
absence of a NATO track in Vilnius as a
victory for Russian President Vladimir
Putin this is not an easy knot to work
through realistically this conflict is
going to grind on and on the cost of the
war while horrific have not yet been
high enough to force the two sides to
sit at the same table it's clear that
Ukraine will become the Taiwan of
Eastern Europe of sorts with lots of
Western Security assurances bundled in a
way that hopefully deters future
aggression but let's face it a lot of
assurances just isn't the same as one
for all and all for one and that's the
bottom line
thank you foreign
[Music]